it's on again June 12 Singapore the
summit and today top North Korean
official delivering a letter that was
eventually read were told by President
Trump as he headed out to Camp David
but the summit is back on and where do
we go from here let's bring in our panel
Tom Bevan RealClearPolitics co-founder
and president Leslie Marshall syndicated
talk radio host and Molly Hemingway
senior editor at the Federalists Tom
significant we've talked about how the
terminology is kind of changed and how
the president is saying you know it
might be one might be two might be a
number of summits walking back
expectations a little bit but it seems
the president still believes that
denuclearization is on the table not
sure that that that's where the North
Koreans are but yeah look the summit is
now back on track and by all accounts is
going to happen in less than two weeks
and we were just told you know by
everybody and not too longer that it was
would be impossible for this to happen
and and yet here we are so listen I was
wrong
do you remember less than was on your
show when we were in Los Angeles I said
it would be on I was correct there but I
said it wouldn't happen on the 12th and
again it still may not you know I think
that Kim jong-un and the president North
Korea in the United States have very
different ideas of what denuclearization
mean and I don't think that Kim jong-un
is going to budge with regard to the
troops being on the peninsula in South
Korea I don't think there'll be any kind
of a deal unless all troops are gone
we're not going to remove all the troops
so I don't think we're going to be able
to get the kind of deal we want and I
think that's why we're hearing the
posturing that we're hearing right now
from both the President and Pompeyo with
regard to this is gonna take a little
time we're gonna have more than one
meeting and I think that's why because I
think there are two different
definitions here and ideas of what they
hope to achieve I know a little bit
about summits wrote a little book about
Reagan and Gorbachev and you know
sometimes it's an evolution sometimes it
does take more than one and they they
took a Geneva Reykjavik Washington and
Moscow yeah and in this case if you just
think back to when the Trump
administration started there were no
lines of communication open even there
were no back-channel lines of
communication open and here
you have visiting the White House today
a top North Korean official I'm really
actually pretty bad guy who was visiting
the White House bachchi
um yeah which is you know there it's
really interesting just how far things
have gotten I don't think I think it is
good that people are resetting
expectations about what can be
accomplished at this first summit but
just the fact that people are meeting is
really significant it's also worth
remembering that when Barack Obama said
that he would be willing to sit down
with bad guys a lot of people on the
right thought that was a really bad idea
when he said right you know I'm willing
to sit down with people without without
agreements beforehand and I think this
shows that sometimes that is a good idea
sometimes you do have to work with
people who might even be you know pretty
evil people but just to get things going
and that there might be something good
about that you know it's not really
known or talked about much but President
Bill Clinton considered going to sit
down with Kim jong-un and instead sent
Madeleine Albright to have that Kim Jong
Il's I should say the father had that
meeting and that's the picture you have
the Madeleine Albright toasting
champagne with him there was another
meeting that concerned the president
today ticketless I didn't like the
Russian meeting yesterday I said what's
the purpose of that but it could be a
positive meeting if it's a positive
reading I love it if it's a negative
meeting I'm not happy and it could very
well be a positive thing I mean you just
hear what's on his mind I mean you can't
say he's not transparent I mean he
didn't like the Roger meeting but he
doesn't know what the meeting is about
that's what's fascinating to me about
this is Trump is very transparent and
honest which which typically diplomatic
speak is much more cagey and
sophisticated than that and he's he's
willing to say hey we might get
something done we might not we'll see
we'll wait and see
it really does have the appearance of a
guy who's on a high wire without a net
which is you know a spectacle to watch
but also a little bit frightening we'll
see so the but the Russian thing did
upset some in the foreign policy realm
in that Russia going to meet Kim jong-un
as Lee saying essentially remember us
and what are you doing and maybe
sticking their nose in it not only that
I think Russia sticking their nose and
almost everything we do especially our
elections maybe they were helping with
that letter the president read or didn't
read but with regard
to Kim jong-un maybe Kim jong-un and the
North Koreans don't have the maybe we
don't have the upper hand with them or
as much of an upper hand with them as we
think and I think that with that meeting
the president has to remain on his toes
even more so all right let me play this
one last soundbite and that is about the
tariffs and the implication of that from
the president's point of view all of
these countries including the European
Union they charge five times the tech we
don't charge tariffs essentially they
charge five times what we charge
Medeiros and I believe in the word
reciprocal you're going to charge five
times we're going to charge five times
like free trade but I want fair trade at
a minimum I want fair trade there's all
this pushback Republicans Democrats
saying what are we doing with allies but
you know what he Larry Kudlow said this
is a family squabble and we are going to
keep the lines of communication open and
we're gonna see where this goes and it's
free trade is preferable it's also true
that our allies have had really good
trade arrangements with us for a very
long time and there were good foreign
policy reasons for that is we were
trying to help strengthen these
countries during a long Cold War but the
point remains that they charge much
higher tariffs than we do that's not
necessarily a great idea it's not
necessarily in our best interest and
these aren't it's not like we're
breaking up a perfectly free trade
environment here we're talking about
renegotiating some arrangements I
mentioned the politics of this time and
as you look at different places that
could be affected it doesn't line up to
help Republicans in the president's
party in the midterms on this particular
issue I mean it's more Democrats like
sherrod Brown and Heidi Heitkamp and
others who maybe benefit from this I
think it remains to be seen I mean again
this is gonna be an election that is a
base election it is a it is all about
turning out votes and so this is
something that that trumps voters have
this is one of his campaign promises
this is one of the things that he that
animated the base to turnout for him in
2016 even if it knocks down the GDP by a
percentage like by one point I mean you
have a great jobs number today correct
and if it takes it down like 1% as
Wilbur Ross's it might and he says
that's not a big deal in the big picture
you know when you have tax cuts that
you're supposedly paying for by
increasing growth does that affect
people and how they look at this it will
if it affects their pocketbooks I mean
if they're paying more for you know
goods and services that they wouldn't
otherwise paid in October
if you weeks before the election it'll
have a material impact if the economy
keeps humming along and things are fine
even even that it won't affect them so
we'll have to wait and see